With primaries
across the Northeast today,
one thing we're seeing more than
ever before this election season
is hordes and hordes of
pumped-up millennial voters!
Which is why New Hampshire--
or "Nampshire" as we call it--
had to ban ballot selfies
like these.
Uh, officials say
ballot selfies could lead
to voter fraud and coercion,
but how else
do you let your ex-boyfriend
Connor know
you're doing just fine
without him,
and you're living your life
and making America great again?
-(laughter)
-That's how you do that.
Snapchat thought the same thing,
so they filed an Amicus brief
last week
defending ballot selfies.
For the record, Snapchat also
never liked Connor,
-'cause he's a dick.
(Bleep) him. -(laughter)
Snapchat's lawyers said,
"The ballot selfie
captures the very essence
"of that political process
as it happens,
"and thus, dramatizes the power
that one person has
"to influence our government.
Also (bleep) Connor."
-I added the last part. Um...
-(laughter)
So, what are you waiting for?
Pull out a dick, snap a pic,
and then send
the most patriotic selfie
you ever took
in your entire life!
And as silly as this may seem,
I know how the power
of the Internet can be used to
reach people and inspire them.
So, comedians,
what are some other ways
to inspire millennials
to get out to vote? Sara.
The two choices
by each candidate
are "Yas, queen,"
and "Bye, Felicia."
-(laughter)
-HARDWICK: Yes. Absolutely.
-(applause)
-Anthony.
A free mustache wax
with every vote.
-HARDWICK: Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah. -(laughter)
-You got to keep those
mustaches... -For the kids.
-For the kids. -The kids.
-HARDWICK: Jimmy Carr.
-Vice President Kanye.
-(laughter, applause)
HARDWICK:
Right.
Because then you could have
the Kanye West Wing.
HARDWICK:
Absolutely. Oh, and while
we're at it, let's make Honey
Boo Boo a Supreme Court justice.
It doesn't matter
if she's not old enough.
Who gives a (bleep) anymore?
Our country's a reality show.